مدعي عاما هاتا الذي اتهم الرئيس السابق
دونالد ترامب يشن هجوما مضادا على القضاء
عبر القضاء عفوا ردا على اعضاء جمهوريين
في الكونجرس كلمه واحده في اللغه العربيه
تقلب الجمله راسا على عقب المدعي الفن
براج الذي وجه الاتهام في الرابع من الشهر
الجاري رفع دعوه قضائيه ضد عضو جمهوري في
مجلس النواب لمنعه من التدخل في قضيته
وابطال اوامر الاستدعاء للمثول امام
الكونجرس براج تهم رئيس اللجنه القضائيه
في مجلس النواب جيم جوردن في الدعوه التي
رفعها الثلاثاء امام القضاء الفيدرالي في
نيويورك بشن هجوم غير مسبوق وغير دستوري
ضد تحقيقها تهدف هذه الدعوه الى منع
محاوله النائب وزملائه لاستدعاء المدعي
العام الى جلسه استماع امام الكونجرس كتب
المدعي العام في شكواه ان الكونجرس لا
يملك اي سلطه للاشراف على الملاحقات
الجنائيه لولايه امريكيه متهما
حمله صريحه لترهيبه وعرقله التحقيقات
ذكر ايضا بان قرار توجيه الاتهام للرئيس
السابق ترامب اتخذته هيئه محلفين كبرى وهي
لجنه من المواطنين كانت اللجنه القضائيه
في مجلس النواب اصدرت مذكره استدعاء تطلب
شهاده مارك بامي وهو كان نائبا لمدعي عاما
هاتا واشرف على تحقيق ترامب قبل ان يختلف
مع براج حول اتجاه التحقيق وقبل استقالته
طبعا العام الماضي من جانبه قال النائب
جيم جوردن عبر تويتر ان الادعاء وجه
اتهاما لرئيس لم يرتكب اي جريمه قبل
المطالبه بمنع رقابه الكونجرس مدعي عاما
هاتا رد ايضا بتغريده قال فيها ان الاعضاء
الجمهوريين في الكونجرس يقومون بخدعه
سياسيه مطالبا بعدم الانخداع بادعاءات
الجمهوريين على حد قبح
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات